our ambition was to have a general
approach for ets we have to establish
the ETS such so as to ensure an increase
of that price and get more investments
for cleaner technologies our discussion
on the revision of ETS also has an
influence on the development of a
mission quota prices we wanted to reduce
this uncertainty and give the market a
clear signal but unfortunately we were
not able to do that because of a lack of
political will I would live first sang
Lazlo and his team for the hard work and
efforts to secure tangible progress on
the emissions trading system propulsion
the message from the ministers today
should I believe enable us to achieve
substantial progress in the coming weeks
now we must earn our international
commitments into reality and move
forward on the 2030 legislative
framework the first point of discussion
this morning was on the protection of
human health and the environment through
the sound management of chemicals we
appreciated the slovak presidencies
efficient work on the council
conclusions which we gladly welcome
these initiatives will contribute to the
evidence base for further work on
chemicals policy in particular the non
toxic environment strategy which was
called for in the seventh EAP and the
approach to chemicals in the circular
economy